ce qui met en colère c'est lorsqu'il me
dis que la précarité mensuel est un
problème de nanas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je l'appelle tarin j'ai 27 ans je suis
la fondatrice et directrice générale de
règles élémentaires règles élémentaires
c'est la première association française
de lutte contre la précarité menstruel
notre objectif est double c'est
collecter et redistribuer un maximum de
produits d'hygiène intime aux personnes
dans le besoin et lutter contre le tabou
des règles je vous emmène dans la
tristesse de stockage parisien s est
limité en taille mais très précieux en
plein coeur de paris et on a vocation en
avoir plein d'autres partout ailleurs
la précarité monstre haine c'est la
difficulté économique pour certaines
personnes de se procurer des produits
d'hygiène intime soit tout court soit en
quantité suffisante c'est concerne bien
évidemment des femmes sans abri les
femmes sdf mais aussi des travailleuses
pauvres des étudiants de précaires des
familles monoparentales la précarité
mensuel est de multiples conséquences
dramatiques aussi bien sur le plan
psychologique avec un sentiment de honte
de gênes d'humiliation que physique avec
des infections et des maladies pouvant
entraîner jusqu'à la mort dans les cas
les plus graves de syndrome du choc
toxique
[Applaudissements]
à ce moment là ça m'a frappée je me suis
rendu compte que je ne m'étais jamais
posé la question de comment ces femmes
faisait quand elles avaient leurs règles
pour gérer leurs règles à la rue très
concrètement et je me suis aussi rendu
compte par la même occasion qu'on ne
m'avait jamais se désister pour ce type
d'opération en france
[Applaudissements]
et la réponse était unanime c'est eh oui
on n'y a pas pensé
et donc je me suis dis que c'est
collectivement on n'y avais jamais pensé
c'était soit qui avait pas de besoin
soit qu'il y avait un énorme tabou
malheureusement l'expérience a montré
que c'était un énorme tabou
je me suis dit que j'aime attaquer à ce
problème et j'ai lancé la toute première
collecte de produits d'hygiène intime en
france en novembre 2015 dans dans
l'université où je faisais mes études
[Applaudissements]
des sénateurs principalement des hommes
très âgées penser que ça n'en était pas
heureusement en seconde lecture
l'abaissement du taux de tva et la
reconnaissance du caractère de produits
de première nécessité a été reconnu les
avantages de ce timing c'est que les
françaises et les français ont vraiment
pris conscience du coût de ces produits
[Musique]
on a obtenu la gratuité des protections
périodiques en prison on a obtenu qu'à
la rentrée 2021 des distributeurs soit
installé dans toutes les universités de
france afin que les étudiantes et accès
gratuitement à des protections des
jeunes intime de qualité
[Musique]
je montre du coup on a mis la boîte à
dons l'élémentaire donc on a mis juste
ici à côté de la caisse à proximité de
la porte d'entrée pour ce soit le plus
accessible pour les clientes
[Musique]
le but étant justement de sensibiliser
des clientes que l'on a déjà en boutique
je pense que toutes les femmes elles
sont même si elle ne le disent pas sont
engagés c'est des choses qui les
touchent particulièrement
engagez vous êtes une collecte allait
donner un point de collecte est vraiment
mêlée une façon de s'investir et on a
besoin de vous parce que la précarité
menstruel et la lutte contre ce fléau
ça nous concerne toutes et tous